so just static first
he's gotta we're gonna start in jab
grange okay
okay
the jab jab range all right somewhere
around there
just static okay
when he throws the jab i turn
i don't look away from the fight
i don't want to change my posture oh
boom okay and then this is going to go
back in
that's the energy so using kimusubi yo
boom i follow it back in
watch where it goes
it's behind it do you think
this is late you're to hit him his car
so
again
[Music]
boom
boom boom back in
what i don't want is the pause he goes
back and no this is wrong the drill is
back in okay follow his strike in go
okay so some fighters like maya they
have to open they're open here in the
middle do you see that
okay
so you would be able to identify that as
the fight what's going on like oh this
dude's opening them right boom
um
you would see it it's not uncommon okay
it's a flower you're thinking you have
gloves on in the street so you do this
you see and the glove would be over here
over here over here it's a habit okay
so uh when you do that one go you come
here and his hands are open you see
that's in the way okay
so you have to follow the union space
boom it's here this is uppercut okay but
it's the same thing
boom
whom energy back
not whom his turn my turn no okay
kimusuki pull in
okay let's go
all right um
let's do another little drill before we
start putting it together okay
um
this guy
we'll just do a simple drill okay so
he's he's moving at me and i keep that
distance do you see he goes i don't let
him close it
he goes and i don't expand it do you see
just a very simple drill stay with him
okay we'll send it up again
pay attention that he's not moving and
then we move
i moved with him
[Music]
okay let's try this down okay he said
don't read it don't read it in a drill
it's just a simple drill i keep the same
distance between him do you understand
don't read into it oh i'm in the world
champion no you're not you're just
[\h__\h] he's moving you're moving that's
it okay
keep your guard up
why because i said just keep your guard
down and then keep your base neutral
okay
so don't get yourself on a tight rope
tight ropes are not marshalled
tightropes are not marshall i wouldn't
get in this fighting horse either okay
don't get flat-footed because i want to
emphasize mobility here changing
direction nothing's going on yet so i
don't pick an angle and go this is my
angle i go with it okay
so i'm in my neutral stance he goes and
i keep that same neutral stance do you
see that i don't start getting on the
line
losing my width here getting flat-footed
getting heal waited
we go
i move it
okay go
okay from this simple ability this
kimusuki
tactically i want to be out of range of
his strikes
uh but not so far out of range yet i
don't have struggles okay
so uh in other words he moves i don't
want to go back here
i want him right in range
for that sweet spot counter okay you got
it
you see
not here
right in range
boom for the sweet squat counter okay
so we'll do the first one when he feels
he has that jab
right
i'll follow it right back in okay
you go slow with your tab and the cross
comes back slow right okay your kid
decides to pace so i'm not out here
because i'm never going to get
entire sim it ties them
in okay let's try that
all right there's a kind of eye hand
coordination going right to the uh
to the ballistic strike you see that
because i'm not touching him at that
point okay if i have to aim
you want to make sure you can see you
want to bring your eyes into it okay
it's just like you're shooting you don't
want to look to the top of your eyes you
want your eyes open
because the eyes are going to direct
your hands and your sides okay so i go
over here and i'm like whoa
you're probably going to miss that thing
okay
so even as i weave home i'm looking you
have to not have the fear go whoa shut
you down okay stare at his fist
stare at his fist see his fist go
okay then you won't miss all right try
it now he's up highest part
you see and you'll see it when he's
dancing you'll see it as he's dancing
around okay
so i'm going to do the same
[Music]
okay not uncommon especially as we're
going around he's trying to get me
trying to get me this is starting to
open even on him you see you're coming
around more you see that you open it
and then
he didn't do it but a lot of people
become very focused on the jab and they
start to drop the other hand okay
so i'm looking for that situation you're
going to drop that other hand for me
okay left back oh
and i'm going to throw this short left
hook okay
so
we go go slow so they can see a little
slower their chances okay okay
oh i'm looking forward
right in there okay right to the bottom
don't break the same mistake and drop
your hand
your hand is up
right in there okay let's try it okay so
you're just mad at resistance now okay
he's just he's not my target now he is
representing resistance to target do you
understand
so i i'm not doing what you think like
boxing hands
i have to be able to punch above my
weight class so i have to round factor
everything okay so
when i do my it's not hip rotation
it's ground vectoring okay so the ground
vector is going through you see when i
do my cross oh it's going through
i'm gonna displace matter at a minimum
okay
and then the same thing
on the hook on the hook
right i'm not going
here like this it's ground vectoring
it through
everything through here boom through
okay
so
i'm here and then
boom
this foot starts on this foot goes to
the other boom and i put his mask into
that foot you got it okay so you're
going to do this drill now your hair
feel going to be the back wall of the
foot
boom through and then the other one
is over here move starts there and goes
here pull in okay go
okay so she's doing these this ground
vectoring on this mass she goes
now
okay
feel that crown cross on that left foot
let's get a little bit more uh dynamism
to it
um
he's gonna oh he's gonna get the jab and
i'm gonna work the kimusubi on one of
these things okay well my target
selection might change because a lot of
you have different styles and once you
go dynamic your style comes out you're
not given the openings but the good new
is going to give different openings so
that you can train the noggin good okay
key to this though
is he goes
and you're caught flat footed do you see
that keep keep the musubi you can move
around if you want right and get him to
beat him with the jab it can be a little
more dynamic and then your job is to get
that jab jab oh and so i can start
working my things do you got it so you
can move around a little more all right
and you get those things going okay all
right here we go again don't
read into the drills you're not fighting
yet it's just a micro moment of the
variable
uh the ever changing mind okay so for
example we go and now you guys are here
like this
you get it and this is going to be
grappling ranging things like that okay
and how did you get there well if how
you got there so he's coming close right
like boom
he's in range of your hand strikes you
see that
um so
just work oh this was the money that we
work
i worked at mine
you see that's where the counter happens
so it's not when i'm in range to throw
my strikes it's not when it's in range
for him to throw his strikes i'm just
slightly out of that range do you see
that and then he goes for it anyways
okay
oh likewise
we go back right and he goes he's coming
in oh and in real life that would be
another range do you see we're not
working that range you got it so you
just work the range from the micro drill
and the micro drill is here he can't
can't reach me from here you see i can't
reach him from here
but i stay just outside of that you're
gonna have to do better than that
okay boom there it is right there do you
understand okay and then likewise when
i'm here boom i'm not going to jam my
strikes do you see i'm going to keep
myself in striking rate so i'm in
striking right
so i can do my strikes okay so they're
still viable and they're not jammed here
and this is just a little
tummy table okay
so try it again pay attention to the
lives very dynamic okay go
okay um
so i have to in order for me to start
getting these counters as i said
i have to put him where he's bridging
with the jab that's technically what
he's trying to do okay
meaning if he if in this drill he moves
in without throwing any strides oh i'm
an attacker okay so i'm just outside of
my own range which means i'm just
outside of his own range and that's why
he bridges with it and instead of doing
this this time right i do this this time
boom you got it okay and towards that
end i'll be better off if i'm not going
straight back like in the administrative
drill okay
so
i'm always circling
and not going off uh trying to interrupt
his rhythm try to see when he sets up do
you get it and try and get him to set up
okay so i'm here like this
and
i'm moving
he tried to turn and then he sat do you
see and then he bridged and i'm looking
for that okay that's what i want to know
i don't want to sit here
because that's not gonna happen okay
keep things moving keep things moving
okay got it all right go